wanna be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only jordan peterson
let's say you want to fix up your house
which is actually quite a lot like
fixing yourself up which is a very
common dream metaphor yeah well the
first thing you want to do is go look
around and see what needs to be fixed
you know and this the interesting thing
about that and this is akin to what
comedians do is that as soon as you're
willing to admit comedians look at a
problem and then rise above it right
away and make a joke about it but as
soon as you're willing to admit that you
have a problem
then you're you've immediately contacted
the part of yourself that's at least
strong enough to admit that you have a
problem and so as soon the act of
admitting the problem is actually the
first step to solving it yes you might
say well and it's an optimistic step
because you you might say oh my god i
can't admit to i that i have a problem
because what if i can't solve it well
exactly so then maybe you won't admit to
it if you do admit to it you're
simultaneously admitting to the
possibility that you could solve it yes
and then it can actually become
something that's optimistic you can say
well my life is horrible it's like okay
but i'm doing 50 things wrong well great
i could fix those things and then maybe
it wouldn't be so horrible a lot of
people don't read because they're afraid
of books
the books aren't their friend so you
might want to get a few books and kind
of make them your friend
you can start with
simpler books you know like fiction
there's lots of good fiction written for
adolescents and children
it's pretty straightforward you can
start there
if you're interested in philosophy
there's lots of
simple guides like the idiot's guide to
um
different topics or a beginner's guide i
read those things all the time when i'm
first investigating a new topic
you know i start with the introductory
material
um and i make time for reading like
what and it was that was encouraged in
my family like i always read before i
went to sleep i read
and i i still do that
somewhat less so because i've become so
distracted by social media
but uh
you set aside a bit of time every day to
read and for me it was always just
before i went to bed i go to bed turn
the light and read for when i was a kid
for hours but
and if you do something every day you do
a lot of it and so i would say well if
you want to read if you want to make
yourself educated just put aside
20 minutes a day to read or 10
you know some small amount of time that
you could actually steal not two hours
because good luck man
it's very unlikely you'll manage that
but 20 minutes a day
you know that's
two hours a week that's 700 hours a year
you know that's
even if you're a slow reader that's a
good number of books
and so you make it a habitual part of
your life and you decide that it's going
to be something that you value you
investigate carefully what resistances
you might have to that idea because you
might think well that's
uh
pseudo-intellectual or
there's something more productive i
could be doing or i'm intimidated by
books or i hate books because i wasn't
good at reading when i was a kid and was
humiliated because of it or you know
you've got something against
intellectuals or
god there might all sorts of resistances
to
picking up a book then you could listen
to audio books that's a good way around
that by hooker by crook man
so
you value it you make it a regular part
of your life you practice doing it and
and you you need a higher goal too it's
like well why should you read
well
it's so that you're more informed and
you can think better
why should you be more informed and
think better because you won't walk
blindly into so many pits
you know you'll be able to negotiate
better in your life because you'll be
more
informed
and more verbally fluent and you'll have
a better sense of how the world works
and be able to hold your own in
conversations and that'll make you more
confident those are all unbelievably
good reasons to be highly literate is is
an incredibly
massive massive advantage
practical advantage you know and it
shouldn't be underestimated i've had
clients many clients in their 30s who
are trying to
this is more true with women i would say
a lot of women who are very high
achieving who establish their career
goals at 30 and then
want to differentiate their
differentiate out their life they want
to have a husband they want to have a
family they're trying to figure out how
to do that and one of the things i've
noticed that around 30
you really have to stop comparing
yourself in some ways to other people
and the reason for that is that the
particularities of your life are so
idiosyncratic that there isn't anyone
really all that much like you you know
because the details of your life happen
to matter and so maybe you compare
yourself to some rock star or something
like that and you know the person's rich
and famous and glamorous and all that
but you know they're alcoholic and they
use too much cocaine and they've had
three divorces and it's like how the
hell do you make sense out of that is
that someone
that you should judge yourself harshly
against or not the answer is you don't
know because you don't know all the
details of their lives and who do you
know that you can compare yourself to
that's easy
you
yesterday
so here's a good goal it's something
like well aim high and i really mean
that it's like and we'll talk about that
a little bit too aim high but use as
your control yourself it's like so your
goal is to make today some tiny
increment better than yesterday and you
can use better you can define better
yourself this doesn't have to be some
imposition of external morality you know
you know where you're weak and
insufficient where you could improve you
think okay well this is what i'm like
yesterday if i did this little thing
things would be just
an increment better
and
well that's a great thing because you
get the ball rolling and
incremental improvement is unstoppable
you can actually implement it and it
starts to generate pareto distribution
like consequences it starts to compound
and i've seen that happen in people's
lives over and over people write me all
the time and tell me that they're doing
that but i've seen that happen to in
people's lives continually they make a
goal a goal that the goal should be
how could i conceive of my life so that
if i had that life it would clearly be
worth living so i wouldn't have to be
bitter resentful deceitful arrogant and
vengeful when you're trying to lead
people forward out of the darkness let's
say um out of anxiety and depression and
despair and and resentment bitterness
and anger and all of those things
catastrophic
interactions with their family is that
you get them to stop avoiding
confronting the terrible things that are
in front of them right so basically what
you do instead of saying to them you
know those terrible things that are
happening just ignore those and and find
some peace right get your mind away from
it that is what you say you say turn
around and look at them even more than
you've been looking at them it's very
paradoxical advice but of all the things
that have been proven to aid people's
recovery and movement towards mental
health that's like at the top of the
list voluntary confrontation with what
you are afraid of
or or what you despise even for that
matter and so
jung had an axiom that he derived from
the alchemist which was instir qualis
inventor which meant roughly meant
that which you most need will be found
where you least want to look
which is
yeah well that's here that was also his
explanation for why people weren't
enlightened
because you think well the california
approach to enlightenment to speak you
know kind of satirically is follow your
bliss it's like well that's easy if that
was the case everyone would be
enlightened but the union approaches no
no no you do what's meaningful
and pay attention follow the truth and
it will take you to the worst place you
can imagine and then maybe there's some
chance for enlightenment it's hard to
say what the soul means metaphysically
because you know say beyond the cons
beyond the confines of a single human
being
we do have this sense that the soul can
expand itself into something that's
greater than
well greater than it has been it has
this capacity for growth
and we do have the sense that
the soul can expand itself to the point
where it it's
enlightened for lack of a better word
that it's working
as efficiently as possible
to transform everything that's
unnecessarily painful and malevolent
about the world into what's positive and
good and and and that it does that as a
consequence of confronting the world
with courage and truth and i i think
that's right
and i do think that that means that the
soul participates in something eternal
which is the attempt of being itself
to transform what's
unnecessarily painful and malevolent
into what's good and that human beings
actually do participate in that and that
that's part of the reason that our
ancient tradition insists that we're
made in the image of god
and i think that it's a mistake to
underestimate the importance of that
because
i don't think that you can live life
a life of sufficient profundity to
protect yourself from being corrupted by
suffering malevolence without
adopting
a
responsibility that's commensurate with
that set of ideas
i think that you either
orient yourself upward
you know to the star above the horizon
and try desperately to improve the
structure of being
or you work at counter purposes to it
and make things worse i don't think
there's a middle ground
in fact to the degree there is a middle
ground it tilts towards the negative
because people who try to occupy the
middle ground
um
try to
generally try to accrue the benefit
let's say without
adopting any of the risk and that's not
acceptable
not helpful
so
that's a soul to me i've watched the
audiences very carefully and listen to
them
to see what resonates and and what
doesn't and
i think the
the the basic argument that i've been
laying out
is that
well
we all have difficult lives you know
that life is characterized in in large
part by suffering
there's an inevitable element of
suffering in life i mean obviously
that's symbolized in christianity by the
crucifixion
which is a very harsh symbol and
and not only is life sorrowful
in in in part but it's also touched by
malevolence and malevolence of each of
us and the malevolence of our social
creations our societies and even in some
sense the kind of blind malevolence of
nature and
so it's it's it's it's it's a demanding
occupation to
to exist as a human being and you need
something
to
sustain yourself through that it's not
optional
because the
the price of existence is so high that
without that sustaining meaning
it it it corrupts you
it embitters you and and once you're
embittered things go downhill rapidly
you get vengeful and and you get angry
and and you get destructive and then
there's really no limit to that and i've
been suggesting to people that
the sustaining meaning that they can
find in their life isn't to be found
through happiness let's say because
happiness doesn't work when you're not
happy when when when when things have
gone badly for you for for even for
accidental reasons but
you can find sustaining meaning and
responsibility
and you can take responsibility
for yourself
you can do that
and if you take responsibility for
yourself you treat yourself as if you're
someone that's worthy of
care
and and discipline
and then that has nothing to do with
being soft on yourself
or the pursuit of pleasure any of those
things you can take responsibility for
yourself and that works and then if you
do that properly you can take
responsibility for your family and then
if you do that properly you can take
responsibility for your community and
you can continue to
burden yourself voluntarily let's say
with with a greater and greater range of
existential challenges and all that that
does is make
more and more
and more of you
and
that
works as an antidote to the catastrophe
of life what's the best method to retain
what you read
and to be able to use it in conversation
oh well
it's very difficult really to retain
anything without recalling it
so
look if you encounter something
and then you encounter it again you can
usually recognize that you've
encountered it before that's recognition
memory so it's it's an important form of
memory it's it's it's the memory that's
associated with familiarity but it's not
the same as being able to use something
exactly it's a rather shallow form of
memory even though it's necessary
in order to be able to use something
you have to recall it this is also very
useful hint for studying like if you're
studying and you have to remember what
you want to do is study
and then you want to write down what you
just learned so you read a paragraph you
close the book and you write down what
you remember or you read a
chapter and you close the book and you
write down what you remembered or at
least you sit there and you try to
remember because the way you remember is
by practicing remembering
okay so
if you're reading and you want to use it
in conversation
and you have to think about what you
read you have to
put it in your own words
it's often helpful to close the book and
write it down or to associate it with
some problem that you're
currently trying to solve you have to
take the knowledge and make it your own
and then
and then that alters the structure
through which you look at the world and
that changes the way that you think so
that when you have a conversation the
next time that you're going to have the
conversation in a different way so
merely reading isn't enough you have
you have to read and think and recall
and it's the act of recalling that
produces the remembering and it's that
act of remembering that puts that
material at hand for you that's why
humility is always stressed in in great
religious traditions humility is
precisely that it's like you have to
look at
why you're not so good
yeah and and you know that that has to
break down your pride to some degree in
your arrogance it's like well that's
great because if you break down your
pride and your arrogance then you're
primed to learn and you can solve your
problems so there's nothing in that it's
a bit crushing to begin with because you
might think oh my god there's really a
lot of things wrong with me yeah but at
least then you're on the on the road to
fixing them i just found out i'm having
a girl
congratulations what can i do to raise
her to think for herself
and not fall into the modes of thinking
proposed by popular culture
well
you can let her think for herself when
she's a kid
you know what you do is so that she
practices doing that you know um
and so that means to
consciously encourage as much autonomy
as possible
so
how do you do that well let's say she's
a little kid she's three and she start
to get interested in clothing so you lay
clothing out on the bed and you say well
you can wear this or you can wear this
you let her make autonomous decisions
you know with kids
you don't want to let them
choose from an infinite menu you want to
give them a constrained menu but
what you want to do with your daughter
is allow her to make as many decisions
as she can possibly make as early as
possible
you know and that doesn't mean that
children always know what's best for
themselves or any nonsense like that it
just means that you're going to
encourage her autonomy to every
in
every measure that you can manage that
means you're going to have to be brave
and allow her to subject yourself to a
certain number of risks
so
you you you raise her to think for
herself by
letting her think for herself
and and that can start that can start
quite early
um
i would say when she's a teenager she's
going to fall into the modes of thinking
proposed by popular culture because
that's part of being enculturated and
socialized it's virtually inevitable and
it's even somewhat desirable but what
you hope is that you've
you've encouraged the capacity for
autonomous thinking to a sufficient
degree that it's likely to
integrate with that more intense teenage
socialization and then re-emerge so you
get someone who comes out the other side
as an autonomous individual and that
works with boys and girls so
so you know let's
i guess you do what geppetto did in
pinocchio is the first thing you decide
is well you don't want to raise a puppet
you know you want to raise an autonomous
person and and then you think through
what does it mean to be an autonomous
person what sort of person do you want
your child to be what
what sort of person do you want to
encourage your child to be
and then
having having having established that
vision in mind that's going to guide
your choices but at least you're making
the right choices you don't want someone
who's dependent and whiny and cringy and
and
and more frightened than they need to be
and
martyred martyr-like and vengeful and
malicious and manipulative and
mendacious all of those things you want
someone who
can
make their own judgments you can ask
kids what they think pretty damn early
like you have to be careful and not push
them beyond their capacity but
if you know your child you'll be able to
see what level of decision making
they're capable of engaging in and then
you would encourage them to mature as
rapidly as they can you know and that
also means that you have to
not
allow yourself to fall too in love with
the
dependent and needy creature that your
infant will be to fulfill your own
emotional needs
you want to detach and and encourage to
mature as rapidly and as comprehensively
as possible and that will work
you know and
some of that's it some of that is
negotiation with your child you find out
what they think it's like what do you
think about this
what do you think about who should do
the work in the house how should we
split it up like they can be engaged in
the decision-making process is a very
early age
and
and
part of that
that encouragement is
going to be reflected in your implicit
attitude that the child is a real person
who's
capable of
imposing their will
in a realistic sense
in the world on the world and doing that
in a
competent and
excuse me competent and confident manner
it's better to have a plan you know
what's the idea
if you don't have your own plan then
you're the tool of someone else's plan
so that's probably not
good especially if you don't know what
their plan is
so so that's useful you could do that
head down endurance
and that'll get you through bad times
that endurance it's it's it's such an
under
represented virtue that ability to
trudge forward under a
trudge forward unhappily under uh
unfairly burdensome load is a testament
to character if you can
and then it's something that should be
encouraged and
valued
so
you know i'm not making the claim that
people who are depressed who can't get
out of bed lack endurance some do and
some don't because depression comes in
very
varied
um degrees of intensity and and you can
be laid out completely by depression
so i'm not
trying to make some arbitrary judgment
about who's got endurance and who hasn't
you can't do that from the outside but i
can say that
endurance is one of the tools you have
to deal with chronic discomfort and pain
you know and even if you have chronic
pain it's interesting because it's very
much allied with depression by the way
all of the research on chronic pain back
pain for example indicates and chronic
pain of all sorts is that
the more you allow your pain to render
you inactive
the worse the outcome including
exacerbation of the pain and depression
is a pain disorder and so that's very
much worth thinking about too it's like
move forward move forward move forward
you know and if you need to talk to
somebody about what your plan is for the
day or the hour or the week then do that
as well and perhaps you also have to
help get the people around you to help a
bit i need a little bit of help getting
up in the morning i need to have
breakfast made for me so that all i do
when i get up in my in my terrible state
of fog and confusion and terrible
anxiety and depression is i have a
shower because that's what happens first
and then the next thing is i eat and
then that's better you're at least
you're out of bed and moving and that's
that's a start you know
so
and then you endure and hope and that's
how it is and you do the same thing when
someone in your family is sick or when
you're facing a death all of that it's
like one bloody foot in front of the
other
up the hill you act out the things that
you would do when you're normal even
when you're depressed you know you don't
want to see people well it doesn't
matter you go see them because it's
better than not seeing them you know and
you find when you do see them that it's
better it'll go better than you think
but you can't isolate yourself and
you're anxious and so you want to avoid
you don't want to go out you'd rather
stay home and sit in the chair and just
sit there and like in a frozen position
it's like you can't do that you have to
go out and go grocery shopping and go
out and have coffee and all of those
things it doesn't matter whether you
enjoy them
it matters that you do them because
that's what you do that's what you do in
order to maintain your health you can
ask yourself that question what would
make this worthwhile
need i quote ninja i think in that
chapter he said he who has a why can
bear almost any how
that's a lovely line man i mean it's a
lovely line and it's really worth
thinking about so you think well
how do i manage all this misery and
suffering and futility it's like well i
need to figure out what i would have to
do in order to make that clearly
worthwhile and so then you have your
goal and then you think well i need to
move towards that incrementally because
i'm kind of useless and can only do so
much and maybe not even that and but all
i have to do is be a little bit better
than my
my miserable self yesterday
and that'll propel you forward very
rapidly and and you can succeed at it
which is also really lovely because why
not set yourself up for success you know
because otherwise you droop around like
a number 10 lobster and you know that's
just not good you get all pinchy when
that happens and it's not a good thing
so i already knew that i was pretty
decent monster by the time i had kids
and i thought well
my kid my kids little you know like a
baby or two year olds like i'm a
horrible monster and so there's an
uneven power problem here i better not
let that child do anything that really
makes me angry
you know now you hear now and then you
hear about something horrible that
happens i when i was in boston years ago
i read about a woman who'd plunged her
two-year-old daughter's arms into
boiling water you think well how in the
world can that happen it's like well you
know
she's probably hungover
she probably just lost her job she was
probably desperate in six different ways
she probably didn't have any decent
discipline out of disciplinary
strategies for children she probably
didn't have anyone helping her she was
bitter and resentful and angry and the
child misbehaved at exactly the wrong
moment and like you're going to be
around your children a lot and so you
might want to have it so that they don't
misbehave at exactly the wrong moment
because all hell can break loose if they
can and i didn't want that to happen so
and i knew that it was easy for people
to hate their children even though they
mouth the words that they love them all
the time i saw very little evidence of
that many situations and so
one of the things you know you have a
natural affinity for children and even
more maybe a more powerful natural
affinity for your own children so that's
a good start but you don't want to set
them up as an enemy against you you
don't want to allow them to engage in
the kind of hierarchical challenge that
makes you irritable and resentful that's
not a good idea and if the things they
do make you dislike them the probability
that they will make other people dislike
them is extraordinarily high and so you
can consult your own irritability and
you can say look kid i used to tell my
kids this you know when they were three
or four i'd say look i'm not in a very
good mood and i'm likely to be
unreasonable so it'd be best if you'd go
in your room and play for a while it's
like i like you man you're a great kid
but like get the hell out of here for a
while you know and they were fine with
that we trained them already at that
point to be able to go play by
themselves in the room you know which is
something a kid should be able to do
anyways but but you need to know what
sort of monster you are if you're going
to be a good parent and if you think oh
i'm not a monster it's like oh yes you
are you're just an unbelievably
unconscious monster and that's actually
the worst kind
so and then the other thing about that
chapter is there's an idea in it and and
it's an idea that i think's well
supported by the relevant literature
which is that your fundamental job as a
parent especially of a child from zero
to four is to make that child eminently
desirable socially
so what you're you're a successful
parent if when your child is four
all sorts of other children want to play
with him or her that's really the that's
like if you want one marker of whether
or not you've been successful that's it
now some children are a lot harder to
get along with than others and some
children have a harder time playing and
so i'm not saying that every parent who
has a child that isn't popular at four
is is at fault for that i'm not saying
that i'm saying the reverse which is you
can be sure that you've been successful
if your child is not popular exactly but
desirable as a playmate and so then you
think well what have you done for your
child well you've opened up the entire
world of children to them so because
they know how to play which is a very
deep knowledge and it starts to become
inculcated probably at the breast and
certainly in the course of rough and
tumble play at about two years of age
it's a deep embodied knowledge they know
how to play like a good well-trained dog
knows how to play you know you meet a
new dog and you go like this and the dog
goes like this you think oh that dog
i can go like this and it won't bite me
right it knows how to play and a kid
who's awake and alert is just like that
like a well-socialized kid if you know
anything about kids is you can take a
four-year-old make a little play gesture
at them and they'll smile right away and
start playing just right now and that's
what you want for your kids and then
everywhere they go other kids like them
and will include them in their play and
play is the way the children develop and
so if other children include them in
their play then the children develop and
the poor kids that don't get befriended
at the age of four with the literature
on this is crystal clear if your child
is an outcast at the age of four the
probability that anything can be done
about that is almost zero no matter what
you do and i hate to be so blunt about
that but i know the literature and
that's what the literature suggests
there's a part of the brain called the
hypothalamus and it's very very very old
we share it with virtually every animal
that has a nervous system it's
it's
sits above the spinal cord it's
extremely old evolutionarily speaking
and half of it governs fundamental
motivation so
governs hunger for example so if you're
hungry
you posit the existence of something
that will satiate your appetite a peanut
butter sandwich and then you're happy
when you're moving towards the kitchen
and then maybe you get thirsty and the
hypothalamus does that and then maybe
you need to use the washroom and maybe
you're too hot and
that the hypothalamus pops up these
little motivational frames and then
emotions modulate your movement towards
the goal that's established by these
fundamental motivations but that's only
half the hypothalamus the other half is
the origin of the dopaminergic system
that
mediates exploratory striving and
positive emotion and so the way our
brains are set up way below what way
below the neocortex way way older than
that the default position is if you're
satiated in all the important dimensions
then you're curious and explore
well why well because you might find new
resources that could be used to
to to uh
satiate those fundamental motivations in
the future so that heroic drive into the
unknown is
unbelievably archaic
and then it's regulated by fear and pain
you know so you go into the unknown well
you don't want to die so if you get
damaged you experience pain and you want
to avoid pain so you experience anxiety
these are very fundamental systems and
they are reflected in our narratives
that's essentially as far as i can tell
why
the dragon
hoards treasure everywhere the dragon is
an amalgam of predatory stimuli
and fire which is a destructive force
but also very useful so
dragon is something like predatory
destructive entity you might say well is
that real it's like well yeah but it's a
meta category it's like there are lions
and raptors and
um
lizards
let's say uh 60 million years ago when
we were still in trees
the idea that there's a meta predator is
a great idea a meta predator is what all
predators share in common
that's a dragon well what should you do
with a dragon
well avoid it that's one answer another
answer is burn it out of its lair so
that it doesn't have baby dragons
the
an even more sophisticated answer is
well
confront it
you can feed your family with the body
of a dragon there's a higher order moral
principle that needs to be brought into
the situation and you sort of described
that right at the beginning of the
question because you said well
what partly what you do when you move
from an addicted state from a
psychological perspective is move from a
viewpoint of the gratification of
immediate desire and and maybe the
accumulation of things as a marker of
success to the notion that no you
actually have a higher purpose and that
higher purpose might involve being of
service that could be of service to
yourself which means you wouldn't be
addicted anymore because that's not a
good way of being of service to yourself
but of service to yourself and the
broader community however you might
define that that's a higher order
purpose and it can integrate your
motivations at at a level that doesn't
leave you at the whim of impulse
that's the purpose of a higher order
motivation you do what you can to make
the things around you better you better
your family better and then whatever you
can manage in your community
you know um
if you're interested in the drug
addicted and the mentally ill you know
there are volunteer you could volunteer
you could talk to those people and
listen
because then you'd find out what the
hell their problems are and then you'd
have some sense about how they might be
helped you know but that's a hard thing
there's no
helping from above
drug addiction and it's combination of
mental illness unbelievably complicated
problems there's no simple solutions
so and it isn't even necessarily obvious
that the people that you see who are
homeless and drug addicted and mentally
ill don't want to be helped is that
sometimes they have problems that are so
absolutely overwhelming that they can't
be helped
in any real sense you know like if
they're
on unmedicated schizophrenic for example
with a drug problem it's god it's just
it's just a nightmarish
it's a nightmare of insane complexity
because schizophrenia is very very
difficult to deal with even
even
with medication because the
medication that helps people who are
schizophrenic also tends to depress
their positive emotion and decrease
their motivation you know so the
medications are generally helpful and
the proper treatment guidelines if
you're schizophrenic generally are stay
with your medication
because
despite the negative consequences of the
medication which aren't trivial
the consequences of not taking it are
worse and that's a real hobson's choice
right it's a bit of hell in both
directions
but if you really want to know
i would say
go have some
contact with those people
and listen to them
and learn what the problems are maybe
you could start seeing what might be
helpful it's a really complicated
problem
and it's different than the problem of
helping people who don't want to be
helped because
you have to figure out who it is that
doesn't want to be helped first and you
don't want to assume that just because
someone's homeless that they don't want
to be helped
i mean
that doesn't mean that it's easy to
figure out how to help them
it's not easy it's helping people is a
very difficult business and it's a very
dangerous business too because you get
tangled up in ways that you wouldn't
expect and that can be
an occupational hazard let's put it that
way aim at one thing which
was one of my favorite parts of the book
and see how extraordinarily good you can
get at that like when i think that's a
good thing is you've got to aim at
something
it's like otherwise your life is
meaningless well what should you aim at
well i don't know well pick something
pick something aim at it as you move
toward it you'll get wiser then maybe
your aim will change that's okay but at
least it'll change in an informed way
it's like discipline yourself in one
dimension
see what happens
well that's exciting
and i think that's something that's open
for everyone
you can do that
i shouldn't say that because i don't
believe that i think you can find
yourself in a situation that's so dire
that you don't there's no escape from it
but
that doesn't matter because
this still this is the hero myth might
not be
the best we have might not always work
but it's still the best we have
and the fact that it might not work
doesn't mean we should throw it away
it's still the best we have
i mean everyone dies and so we fail in
some sense
the fact that a symphony ends doesn't
mean that it wasn't worth listening to i
speak to my audiences
seriously and pessimistically in some
sense about
part of the substructure of existence
the the mortal side the fragile side
but
conclude i would say that
there's more to you than there is
to what faces you
and i believe that to be true and and
then
i'm encouraging people to to attempt
that and then i think part of the reason
that the book has been
perhaps particularly popular among men
is because i don't think we do a very
good job at the moment of encouraging
men we have this idea that there's
something intrinsically oppressive
about the patriarchy and about
masculinity in general and
i think that's nonsense i think that
strong
honest truthful
courageous
men
pursuing
noble goals is of great benefit to
everyone male and female alike
resentment is a key human motivation and
i would say it's i'm it's a great
teacher to to listen to your resentment
is one of the best things you can
possibly do you have to admit that it
exists first and then you have to admit
to the fantasies that it's generating
and you have to admit to what you would
regard as the way out of it so that's
all
very difficult because it means learning
things about yourself that you probably
don't want to learn but
resentment
only means one of two things it means
either like shut the hell up grow up
quit whining and get on with it that's
one thing it means or
someone is playing the tyrant to you
might even be you you have something to
say and do that you should say and do to
put it to a stop
and so maybe and resentment can show you
the pathway to doing that um
there's a meditation on resentment and
one of the one of the
principles that i extracted from that is
like a resentful person wants other
people to change
and if you're resentful then your
motivations aren't trustworthy in fact
they're very very dark and that's why i
went to the extreme with people like
panzram and the columbine killers
resentful people who want to change the
world are not to be trusted
what should you do instead how do you
treat your own resentment i would say
well there's a there's a great
i read this great line in a ts eliot
play called the cocktail party and in it
this woman comes up to a psychiatrist i
think this is in this chapter and she
says
you know i'm having a really rough time
of it i'm suffering badly my life is not
going well and then she says
i hope that there's something wrong with
me
and the psychiatrist says what the hell
do you mean by that and she says well
here's how i look at it there's either
something wrong with the world and
i'm just in it and that's how it is and
then like what am i going to do about
that because it's the whole world or
maybe i could be fortunate and there's
something wrong with me that's causing
all this unnecessary suffering and if i
would i could just set it right i could
learn and i could set it right
and so
well i've been thinking about that for a
very long time and i think well if your
life isn't going the way it is you know
you can find someone else to blame which
is pretty convenient for you and also
relatively easy or you could think okay
i don't like
life i don't like the way my life is
unfolding
um maybe i don't like life in general
because it's tragic and and tainted with
evil
how do i know if my judgment is accurate
and the question is well have i really
done everything i possibly could to set
my life straight
because maybe i shouldn't be judging it
it's quality or the quality of life
itself or being itself for that matter
if i haven't done everything i possibly
could to set my life straight
well so there's a there's a task
solzhenitsyn who i'm a great i'm a great
admirer of social nits and his book the
gulag archipelago was one of the things
that brought down the soviet union and
he said that one man who stopped lying
could bring down a tyranny and you know
he said that with some authority and i
think you could easily make the case
that the gulag archipelago is the
greatest
book of the 20th century i mean there's
other contenders obviously but
he said when he was in the gulag camps
you know
meditating on how the hell he got there
and he had a rough life man i mean first
of all he was on the russian front at
the beginning of world war ii and then
he was thrown in the gulag camps and
that was just the beginning of his
adventures man he had a rough life and
he was in the camps he was thinking what
the hell like how what how did i get
here what's going on and he had hitler
and stalin to blame right so if you have
if you need someone to blame man hitler
and stellan that that's great but he he
that isn't what he did he said he
meditated for a while once he realized
that he might have something to do with
in some strange way with the way things
turned out for him and he said he went
over his life with a fine-tooth comb in
his memory and thought okay
where did i go wrong but by my own
judgment when
when i when there was a path in front of
me
when did i take the path that i knew i
shouldn't take because you all know that
right you know
sometimes you don't know if what you're
doing is good or if it's bad
it's just ignorance you just don't know
but sometimes you bloody well know and
you do the thing you know you shouldn't
do anyways that happens a lot
and
why do you do that spite is part of it
stupidity there's all sorts of reasons
but you certainly know you do it
soldienson thought okay well what would
happen if i took responsibility for
where i am in this concentration camp
and then i went over my whole life and
tried to figure out all the things i did
that were wrong by my own estimation
that increased the probability that i
would get here and then what would
happen if i tried to set them all right
now in the present
and that's why he wrote the gulag
archipelago and one of the consequences
of that as i said was it sped the
dissolution of the soviet empire so hey
that's not bad eh like you make a real
confession you really repent you you do
your penance which is writing this book
and you completely change the
geopolitical landscape of the world it's
like and that that's worth thinking
about because it's not only solzhenitsyn
who did that nelson mandela did
something quite similar it's not so
impossible and so
the idea that
what you should do if you're feeling
resentful about the nature of being or
suffering too much for your own life
let's say is straighten the damn thing
out like seriously try it for a year
even try it for a week
try not doing the things you know you
shouldn't do
try
not saying the things you know to be
false
and just watch what happens you might as
well give it a shot one of the things
that happens in the mesopotamian
creation myth the anumilish is that
the gods are created they're they're the
offspring of chaos that's a good way of
thinking about it and they become very
careless and they destroy their category
system they destroy their father
essentially and chaos comes flooding
back
and that's what happens to people who
aren't looking at things and delimiting
them properly they become up apocalyptic
and do them in
so but sometimes in uh mythology there
is the positive um
confrontation confronting of the god eg
prometheus so sometimes we need to still
steal the fire sometimes we need to
challenge these orthodoxies don't we yes
absolutely i mean par part of the well
part of the death that you're describing
is actually the confrontation with a
form of tyrant like your previously
addicted self
was the tyrant over your emergent self
yes and so it's an internal tyrant and
you said it was predicated on a false
value system that's a false set of gods
essentially and so you had to confront
that that is a kind of death if you're
seriously suicidal
and you can tell
if you are
if you have a plan like a plan that
you've
that you've played out in fantasy
multiple times if you know how you would
do it and when and where and if you
fantasize about the aftermath like if
that's a well-developed plan then you
should go talk to someone you should
talk to someone professional you should
let a friend know you should let a
family member know like you need to do
that you're at risk you're in danger
under those circumstances
compare yourself to who you were
yesterday
not to who someone else is today and the
reason i wrote that was because i had
this client 10 i'm a clinical
psychologist and i spent 20 hours a week
for 25 years listening to people
listening to people tell me about their
lives you know and and those people were
people who were just barely hanging on
to the bottom of the world up to people
who were so successful you can hardly
believe it like the entire gamut of
people and and that's been absolutely
fascinating it's like it's like being a
clinical psychologist if you really
listen is like being immersed in a
dostoevsky novel all the time you know
because it's amazing what people will
tell you if you listen to them they are
people are so interesting if you
actually listen to them because they're
so peculiar like they're like penguins
or rhinoceroses and ostriches they're
unlikely creatures and
anyways
um with regards to
um
to uh
comparing yourself to who you were
yesterday and not just who someone else
is today um
this old client of mine he was about 85
when he came to see me and he was a
financier and a kind of a mathematical
genius he made these little pendants out
of a
a mathematical symbol for the most
beautiful mathematical equation that was
ever written he made them out of gold
and he would hand those out and and he
had studied psychology as a young man
and he introduced me to this concept
that i didn't know about called the
pareto distribution which see i'd been
taught as a psychologist that most human
characteristics
were normally distributed right so most
people were average and some people were
extreme that that's a pretty or a normal
distribution intelligence is like that
and height there's more people of
average height than very tall or very
short and weight is like that and lots
of things are normally distributed and
psychologists tend to assume that
everything is but it isn't
creative products are distributed in a
pareto distribution and that's a whole
different thing and it's really
important to know this it's another
fundamental fact the knowledge of which
can sort of transform the way you
conceptualize let's say the political
landscape so
here's an example of the pareto
distribution huh you know there's a rule
of thumb that if you run a company that
20 of your employees do 80 of the work
or the 20 of your customers are
responsible for 80 of your sales or the
twenty percent of them are responsible
for eighty percent of the customer
service calls same thing but that's not
exactly the rule the rule is worse than
that the rule is
in a given domain the square root of the
number of people operating in that
domain do half the productive work
so you think well you have 10 employees
three of them do half the work it's like
yeah okay what if you have 100 employees
then 10 of them do half the work
what if you have a thousand employees
well then it's 30 and if it's 10 000
employees then it's a hundred and this
actually turns out to be a rather
iron-clad rule it it it applies across
very very many situations it applies for
example to the mass of stars and the
size of cities so you can see how
universal it is as a law and it's it's
something like those that have more get
more and those that have less get less
that's the matthew principle right to
those who have everything more will be
given from those who have nothing
everything will be taken away and the
economists sometimes call that the
matthew principle and so what what that
lays out is a world that's rife with
inequality so you know you you hear this
idea that i think it's the 85 richest
people in the world have more money than
the bottom 2 billion that's a pareto
distribution phenomena and you might say
to hell with capitalism for producing
that it's like sorry you got your
diagnosis wrong it's a natural law
it's no matter what society you study
you get a pareto distribution of wealth
you get a pareto distribution of number
of records recorded you get a pareto
distribution of number of songs written
or goals scored like any creative
product has that characteristic and it's
partly because as you start to become
successful let's say people offer you
more and more opportunities and as you
start to fail people move away from you
and you plummet and so
okay so that's rough so what it is what
it means is that there is always a
landscape of inequality and i'm not
saying that we shouldn't do anything
about it although i am saying that we
don't know what to do about it that's
the thing you know because you can
modify the pareto distribution of wealth
let's say but if you but we don't know
how to do it without maybe disrupting
the system so completely that it
collapses which is what happened in the
soviet union for example
and in maoist china they were trying at
least in principle to adjust inequality
but the cure was far worse than the
disease and the the truth of the matter
is we actually don't know technically
how much inequality there has to be to
generate wealth we can guess and you
could say well there should be less and
you might say well there should be more
if you're left-wing you'd say less and
if they're if you're right-wing you'd
say well we'll just let the inequality
flourish but we do know that it's
inevitable and we also know that we
don't know how to regulate it so there
is inequality what that means is there's
always going to be people around that
are better at something than you are and
the and that's a that's a problem
because you can get jealous and you can
get bitter and you can get resentful and
worse you can get hopeless you know
because you look like look
i have this this friend of mine he told
me something so funny um he was he was
decrying his his lack of success in the
world and he compared himself to his
roommate
and uh
he said you know his roommate his
college roommate was doing much better
than he was and his bloody roommate was
elon musk it's like
really like it's like oh you're not
doing as well as elon musk well it's i
mean you can see it would take it rather
personally because they were roommates
and everything it wasn't like he was
doing badly like he was doing pretty
damn well it's like i'm not as good as
elon musk it's like yeah well you and
like seven billion other people you know
but but i thought it was instructive
because
well because you have to be careful who
you compare yourself to now you can't
just not compare yourself to others to
successful people right because then you
don't have anything to email one of the
things i've thought about a fair bit is
the meaning of the sermon on the mount
and as far as i can tell it's it's a
it's basically a two-part it's two-part
wisdom
the first is that you should aim at the
highest good that you can imagine
and that would be a good that includes
everyone right so if i wanted what was
good for you say if i genuinely wanted
it i want it in a way that was good for
you now and good in the long run and
good for you and your family and your
community and maybe good for me too you
know you could conceive of that as the
desire and i think that's a good
definition of love is that you actually
want the best you want the best possible
outcome and in the gospels of course
that's extended even to your enemies yes
right is that okay if we're going to
have things good let's have it good
enough for even the people that set
themselves up against me because if the
world was running properly things would
be good for them too and that would be
better and it seems to me that that's a
very good way of looking at things it's
a difficult way of looking at things and
then the second
part of the sermon on the mount is
something like
having established that as your aim
which is no easy thing by the way right
because you have to be pretty
clear-headed and single-minded to
actually want that to be your aim then
you can concentrate on the day and you
can try telling the truth and you can
ally so there's truth and love that are
allied together truth love and attention
it's something like that that are all
allied together
um
with regards to transgressing against
the vulnerable you know what i mean if
you're plagued by boats of depression
and anxiety that does destabilize your
identity
so
it's almost by definition but having
said that
look this is when
habit
and plan
and strategy are so useful so in the
periods of depression that i've had
what's sustained some of them were long
and and and certainly the most
unpleasant experiences of my life
um
you this is when you need
a philosophy let's say that's allied
with your vision and your strategy to
sustain you because what what what would
happen to me is that
i know i have these a vision and i
suppose the vision is of a world that's
better in in that's less likely to
descend into ideological catastrophe and
where people are more responsible and
more awake
and more educated and
and and healthier all of that a vision
of a better world you know a world
that's less hellish at least but also a
better world and
some sense of what role i might play in
that
and and so that's very motivating like
it's a profound goal to try to make
things better and you can do that
locally you can do that for yourself you
can do that for your family you can do
that for the broader community and all
of that's worth it man it's worth making
some sacrifices for it's worth suffering
for to some degree
and then you decompose that into the
day-to-day and week-to-week strategies
and actions that you're undertaking the
plans and and and the activities that
you're putting forward to make that
dream a reality to realize it and then
when the depression and anxiety come
along you think
part of it with depression it's like
it's just bloody endurance it's like
you get up and you
work through the next hour you try to
stay on track you try to implement your
strategic plans to the best of your
ability and you hope and you pray that
you'll get through it
you know you'll get through it and that
the darkness will recede and you
you you stay on track you eat even
though you're not hungry you get up even
though you want to stay in bed you
interact with people even though you'd
rather be alone and it's it's it's it's
the benefit of disciplined habits
can can sustain you it's like the boat
you're rowing in through a terrible
storm leaks and all and maybe you'll be
overwhelmed but you have the boat and
you can roll forward and that's what
you've got and so endurance is a huge
part of it
and then i would say with its anxiety
it's the same thing it's like are very
much the same as you're terrified and
and uncertain but you move ahead to the
best of your ability and again you
operate at least to some degree on hope
and if you haven't got hope then you've
got blind bloody endurance
and that's all motivated by some sense
that you're working towards something
that's worthwhile working toward
you know and and that is well that's
your own long-term well-being to treat
yourself properly it's the stability and
productivity and harmony and health of
your family that's a huge deal
and then it's whatever benefit you can
be to the community
and if you have to limp along and drag
yourself forward in order to maintain
that pathway then so be it
because
it's better than the alternative higher
on the basis of competence
using objective tests and let the cards
fall where they're going to
and don't be afraid to
tell people that that's what you're
doing
watch your hr department carefully and
make sure that they're not pushing
diversity inclusivity and equity
initiatives that they're not requiring
people to
take implicit association tests that
hypothetically reveal their unconscious
bias that they're not doing seminars on
systemic racism and prejudice and then
they're not making the assumption that
unequal outcomes let's say in terms of
hiring in the stem fields or in terms of
employment in the stem fields which by
the way are radically overestimated if
you
unless you gerrymander what constitutes
the definition of a stem discipline
you just have to
you have to not participate in any of
that and you have to make it known to
your peers which who would be other
silicon valley founders i would presume
that you're not doing any of that
because we discovered that we could let
go of something we value in the present
and we would gain something we value
even more in the future we acted that
out dramatically in all sorts of strange
ways over thousands and thousands of
years before it was formalizable
psychologically but it's a massive
discovery i can forego gratification
in a particular way
and benefit in the future so i can share
the proceeds of my hunt
and i store up future food in the form
of reputation
and the favors i've owed i'm owed now by
other people
it's a massive discovery like one of the
things i've learned
if you're
if you have a dispute with someone
and
it needs to be settled and maybe they
need to change more than you and that's
not always the case because sometimes
the settling requires change on your
part but let's say that
they have to be defeated in some sense
in comparison to you you don't want to
defeat them any more than necessary you
know it's like you don't knock your
opponent to the ground and then jump up
and down on them three or four times in
triumph you know you you
you
you pin them and let and then let them
up
minimal necessary force
because any more than that just produces
a counter reaction
and so
and i guess the other thing is too is my
motivation
when i'm engaged let's say in these
discussions is that i'm not trying to
win the argument
i'm not trying to win
i'm trying to say what i think as
clearly as i can and there is
there might be an element
there might be one of the consequences
of that might be
what appears to be a victory but
the right victory is the victory for
your ability to articulate what you
believe
and that's what i'm trying to do and so
that's another reason
to stay composed is like well okay
this person is just throwing a curveball
at me it's like all right so
well
i could be thinking well i don't want to
be undermined by that and i don't want
to make a fool of myself and i don't
want to be put on the spot and of course
all those things are true
but mostly what i'm thinking about is
okay well now i've got that question
i want to answer as truthfully as i
possibly can
what do i think about what was just said
and i'm not calculating the outcome
i'm assuming this is a mark of faith
right this is the faith that
that that people have talked about
being
something that
has to be manifested necessarily we've
been talking about this since the dawn
of time what's the faith
the faith is that if you
say what you believe to be true
then whatever happens is the best thing
that could have happened
and i believe that
so that's and i really believe it
partly because i believe that if you're
deceitful which is the opposite of that
or manipulative or malicious or
malevolent
but maybe primarily manipulative
then what you're acting out is your
belief that deceit will
bring victory and i just don't believe
that at all i i just i think it's a
preposterous claim
and so if seat won't bring victory
then truth is what brings victory if
there is such a thing as truth
and there's certainly such a thing as
deceit so there must be such a thing as
truth
and so
and some of it's just curiosity too it's
like well i'm going to say what i think
and see what happens that's an adventure
you know that's the adventure of your
life
really and you don't want to miss that
because
that's what you've got in your life is
for it to be an adventure it's not an
easy
road you know it's a stormy sea
and
what you have is the adventure of
contending with god in the waves that's
what you have
and
the way you do that is with truth
and
then that sort of takes you out of the
immediacy of the conflict
whoever it is that the conflict with
whoever it is that you're talking to
you're trying to ally yourself with
something that's
deeper and more profound
and more lasting if you don't allow your
children to engage in dislikable
behavior then adults will like them
because adults actually like kids you
know one of the things i loved about
having little kids in montreal i lived
in a poor area in montreal there's a lot
of rough guys around there and we used
to roll our daughter around in the
stroller these rough guys you know like
god only knows what they were up to they
were rough looking guys you know we'd
roll our daughter by them and they'd
they'd like smile and they crouched down
and make little goo faces and you know
they were
you i tell you one of the great things
about having little kids is they bring
out the best in other people you see a
whole side of humanity even among the
darker parts of humanity you see a whole
side of them that you wouldn't normally
see and it's lovely and the thing is if
you're good to your kid in the real way
you can help them maintain that
tremendous attractiveness that they have
as young children and to respond to
adults properly like a puppy that wags
its tail instead of growls and you know
goes for your ankle and then wherever
they go adults welcome them and teach
them things and pat them on the head and
smile at them genuinely instead of
saying oh my god here comes that couple
with that goddamn brat again
you know which is the horrible that's
horrible thing to do to a child because
then everywhere they go all the good all
the good will is false
you know there's nothing that you can do
to someone that's more terrible than to
put them in a world where all the good
will directed towards them is false
that's a terrible thing i took what i
learned about what happened in the
second world war seriously
it's like wow
we can be really bad
we should do something about that
like that was unacceptable
was it or not well how unacceptable was
it change your life unacceptable
better be
if you want it not to happen again
and it's not like it the next time it
happens
we'll make the previous time look like a
picnic
we're way more powerful than we were
you know when we're getting to the point
is something jung talked about
especially near the end of his life
we're getting so powerful that
each individual is now a force of almost
unimaginable destructive power if they
so choose to be
and that's just going to
that power is going to continue to
increase
and what that means is that the degree
to which each of us has our act together
is going to be something
upon which the world increasingly
depends
for its maintenance how do i stop
ruminating these thoughts are recurring
and relate to every and any embarrassing
moment i have ever had during my
lifetime
i'm a 76 year old woman well oh well
here's something you could try
write down everything that you're
ruminating about
i know that seems counterproductive but
like see ruminations come up
accidentally
involuntarily unconsciously
whereas if you write down everything
that you're ruminating about you're
facing them voluntarily so i would say
well
open up a journal or word document
whatever and write down every time you
ruminate about something
write it down and write down every
rumination you can remember exhaustively
write them all down
that would be the first thing and the
second thing is standard behavioral
therapy practice the second thing the
next thing would be
um
write down why you think they happened
so that you get a good causal account
and then write down well what you might
have done about them then
but more importantly what you could do
about them in the future to avoid that
because it doesn't matter that something
embarrassing happened to you once what
matters is
whether or not you're likely to repeat
it in the future but my suspicions are
that even if you just
you could just start simply
write down every ruminating ruminating
thought that you have
voluntarily
and think about them in detail and write
them down in detail get every little
word down
and
then you have that document and then
when you have a thought and start to
ruminate on it
um
then
sit down later after the ruminating
thought goes away and bring it to mind
voluntarily
so every time you have a thought you
don't want to have
later practice having that thought on
purpose
and try that for about a month
and see what happens because it's often
the case that if you start thinking
about
the thoughts you're ruminating on
consciously and confront them
voluntarily that they will start to go
away you know you see these mass
shootings all the time and everyone does
the same thing oh how did that happen
why did that happen how can it be this
way it's like well why don't you read
what they said about why they did it and
just assume that that's the reason and
if you go
if you go
oh well the call of mine kids
oh yeah it was like oh they must have
been bullied oh yes because you know the
natural response of anyone who's been
bullied is to go arm yourself to the
teeth to plot the destruction of the
entire city i think it was of detroit to
line your entire high school avenue with
bombs and then to go and shoot your
classmates that's what happens when
you're bullied it's like no that's not
what happens when you're bullied that's
a stupid explanation it's shallow beyond
belief and it and it really emerges only
because people don't want to contend
with the real issue
and the columbine kids well they were
contending with the real issue you know
they basically said quite forthrightly
that in their own arrogant estimation
being itself was corrupt and unnecessary
and it would be best if it was
eradicated in the most brutal possible
way as fast as possible
and you get to places like that if you
dwell on revenge for three or four years
in your mom's basement you know you can
go to very dark places do what is
meaningful not what is expedient and to
to to view the world as a place of
resources that can be delivered to you
it's in some sense to be expedient is to
take the short term
it's to take the approach of short-term
gratification something like that yes
self-centered it's materialistic too
well it is materialistic but it's also
it's also it's not optimal and it's it's
not wise and the reason for that is is
that it actually turns out like if we're
going to have if we had a continuing
relationship
i would want to try to do a little bit
more for you than you do for me and i
could do that even purely selfishly say
because if i did a little bit more for
you than you did for me you would want
to keep interacting with me and i'll
tell you man if you want to have a good
relationship with someone that's one
thing you don't do you open your bloody
eyes and if they do something that you
would like them to do again
then you
tell them how much you appreciated the
fact that that happened and you hope
that it replicates you know you see that
that's if there's one thing you can take
away from tonight's lecture that's
that's an extraordinarily useful thing
to know watch and when people do
something that they should do more of
say look i saw that you did this
specific thing i saw that it took some
effort here's what it meant here's
here's how i observed it's like keep
that up and man if you love someone you
do that to them that's that's
encouragement that's such a great thing
the positive emotion that we find
sustaining
is experienced in relationship to an
unachieved goal
it's hope that drives us forward we want
something and if we see ourselves moving
towards that
then
we're we're in the grip of the positive
emotion that we find sustaining it isn't
the attainment attainment is satiating
attainment shuts down the system that
has been striving for that particular
object of attainment if you're hungry
and you eat you stop being hungry now
that's good because the hunger is gone
but that whole frame
disappears
you can no longer strive within that
frame
and you need a new frame to strive
towards
and so technically and this is well
established as far as i'm concerned we
even know the drugs that people abuse
cocaine let's say amphetamines the ones
that are potent
sources of positive emotion
activate the system that regulates our
emotional response to evidence that
we're moving towards a desired goal
so cocaine for example
is an exhilarating drug it makes you
feel that things are worthwhile because
it hijacks the system that does make
indicate that things are worthwhile
so this is deeply this this striving
aspect is deeply rooted in in our in our
biology
for obvious reasons your life doesn't
have meaning without aspiration or name
okay so you need a hierarchy of values
there's got to be something at the top
it's got to be something important if
you don't have that your life doesn't
have any meaning so if you criticize the
hierarchy or even the ideas of idea of
hierarchy you destroy the idea of
aspiration and then people have nothing
well that's not helpful people are built
for a struggle and they're built for a
weight and you want to take on a heavy
burden voluntarily see if you can put
yourself together see what you can do
out in the world while you're waiting to
die it's an all-in game it better be
worthwhile
and so there's a tight relationship
between responsibility and aspiration
and hierarchy and when you criticize
those things you get rid of the
aspiration you have to negotiate until
you come to the best solution that can
be negotiated which isn't necessarily a
perfect solution but it might be the
best one that can be done and then you
have to stick with it until the next
negotiation and
if you get upset during the negotiations
which you likely will because these are
difficult topics how to divide up
responsibilities in the house and people
get mad because they feel they've been
taken advantage of or aren't being
listened to
one of the rules was well you can leave
the discussion but only until you calm
down and then you have to come back
because these things have to be pushed
through they have to be negotiated
through because the alternative is well
important things don't get done or
people
do them resentfully because they're sort
of forced by their own orderliness or
their own conscientiousness or
or
but we know by force psychological or
otherwise on the part of other people
these things have to be negotiated
through
you can tell if you've got
the balance between making peace and
speaking the truth right if the
conversation continues and it can be
emotional and will be and can be
difficult because important things have
to be dealt with but as long as
the people are still in the conversation
and communicating then you then you've
got the balance right you know you might
have to take a break
maybe you have to hold off till the next
day
maybe sometimes when you're negotiating
something that's difficult you have to
offer the other person the opportunity
to sleep on their decision too
which i think is often a very good idea
if you have to make an important
decision in your life it's very
useful to tell the person that you're
negotiating with it look i'm interested
in this and it seems good but i'm not
gonna agree until i sleep on it gives
you
well lots of things happen when you
sleep you organize your brain when you
sleep at least to the degree that you
can organize it and you can often be
more solid or more doubtful about a
decision you need a meaning to sustain
you through the vicissitudes of life
okay well try to debate that it's like
is life painful yes is it anxiety
provoking yes is it uncertain yes
is it painful beyond bearing sometimes
yes it's difficult
everyone agrees about that now they
might disagree about how difficult but
that doesn't matter that the central
point holds okay
what if you think that's all pointless
well that doesn't seem very helpful
okay so you need a sustaining meaning
well where do you find that
well
you generally find it in responsibility
to yourself and other people if you're
having a discussion with someone
and they're talking about things that
don't have those characteristics right
that they haven't made personal then the
conversation is almost never interesting
it's because the person is
it's just a
they're just they really are an empty
shell through which
ideologue ideology cliches and slogans
are pouring there's nothing about that
that's compelling because
you don't see
the grappling
you don't see that the other person has
grappled with the ideas and come to
their own unique conclusions
and it really is in that
mingling of the abstract and the
particular that
compelling wisdom is to be found
and so that's
that's
and then
concretely speaking well there's ways of
earning your knowledge and part of that
is
reformulating it in your own words
that's thinking it through right
and discussing it until you have it at
hand you can talk about it and you can
generalize from it because you truly
understand it but a huge part of that is
also putting it into practice and
deriving your own conclusions as a
consequence and some of that can be done
with debate it's like here's an idea i
came across and
here's the idea and here's what i think
it means
and this is
how i think it would change things if i
put it into practice this is how i
understand this idea and what do you
think of that
like that's a good
debate or discussion
you know because then the other person
can say well
i don't really agree with the way you
formulated that or i don't agree with
your conclusions and hopefully it's a
real discussion and not just
one-upmanship you know because that's a
pretty dull game seoul is also
the center of the world
which is a
frightening proposition and and not one
that's easily comprehensible
solzhenitsyn's work in the gulag
archipelago is particularly enlightening
in this regard
because he insisted that it was a pre
preconception of our
judeo-christian heritage that each
person was the center of the cosmos and
you can think of that as
a center of consciousness right a center
from which being itself is not only
reflected but also generated and it was
solzhenitsyn's
belief and dostoevsky's as well and i
think jung would have been in accordance
with this and nietzsche as well
for that matter that
in some manner that we don't fathom
because we don't understand the
structure of the world very well
the
outcome of
the world is dependent on our choices
and and equally on all of our choices
and it i don't understand i know that's
i know that to be true i feel that to be
true
it's it's part of the doctrine that each
person is of
intrinsic and equal worth
part of that doctrine is that each
person is has intrinsic and equal
responsibility
and that we're each capable of
generating a fair bit of hell around us
and for other people but also
capable of generating a tremendous
amount of good
and that the fate of the world as it
careens through
eternity is actually a consequence of
the
ethical decisions of each of us it's a
terrifying idea
it's no wonder people flee from it into
hedonism let's say an and ideology
because
it's very
frightening
possibility that
the choices that you make day to day
or fail to make
have this profound and lasting effect on
the structure of reality but i don't
really see any way out of that
conclusion because it's one thing to
live properly and that's not a trivial
thing but it's another thing to be able
to articulate yourself and to be able to
negotiate and generally speaking there's
nothing about that that isn't
advantageous and even introverted and
anxious people can learn to do that you
know it's those are learnable skills
it's not easy but but
but you can manage it
you can also
you can also speak carefully you know
and listen to what you're saying and
only try to say things that you think
are true that's also unbelievably useful
you have to feel that out like is this
really what i believe or am i putting it
forward well because i want to look good
or i want to dominate or
or i want to express
obliquely an emotion that i'm too
cowardly to come out and confront
directly or am i being manipulative
there's lots of reasons that people use
language but what you really should use
it for is to state what you believe to
be true and then to let the consequences
of that unfold
and so that can also
help you
simple truths
bluntly stated can be very powerful you
don't need a lot of verbal fluency under
those circumstances if there's evidence
of strength of character behind it look
it's good for you to go take your place
in the world have some ambition
have some have a vision have a goal have
a strategy try to try to be a good
person in not not because it's your duty
precisely because that's the proper way
to live we're in danger of undermining
all of that and it's not good for people
one of the things that i've really
learned for example recently is that
there's a or learn to articulate better
is that there's a very tight
relationship between aspiration and
responsibility so let's say
well the first question might be do you
need to aspire to something and the
answer is well yes because you have to
do something okay if you just sit there
you'll die you can't just sit there you
have to go act out in the world okay so
act towards what
well that's whatever your aspiration is
you have to have an aim okay well what
should the aim be well it should be
something worth doing let's say what why
do something that you don't feel is
worth doing what do you think's worth
doing well if you watch other people and
you judge when they're doing something
worthwhile usually judge them positively
if you see that they're taking
responsibility at least for themselves
when you want to be completely useless
so other people have to take care of you
that's pretty pathetic and maybe you
could get your act together so you're
taking care of yourself and your family
and maybe you could even do better than
that and take care of yourself and your
family and your community there's lots
of ways of defying the crowd let's say i
mean
you could live your life the way that
you want to live it that's a matter of
action
you know and they say actions speak
louder than words and one of the best
things you could possibly be is a
inspirational example
so that's not nothing
um
that's that's something live properly
in your defiance of the crowd right
make your own course
allow yourself to be guided by your own
genuine principles you don't necessarily
have to advertise that which is in some
sense what you're doing
when you when you're debating
because you're taking the manner in
which you act like if you're an
integrated person and you're
articulating that
um but maybe you can't do that because
you don't have the verbal skills well
then the question would be maybe you
should develop some more verbal skills
i like i don't know this for sure dave
you know but but generally it's useful
how do you do that um
doesn't hurt to read
really doesn't hurt to write you know a
little bit of writing every day
clarifies your thinking you need an idea
because you have nothing to aim at but
an ideal is a judge and you always fall
short of the ideal so how the hell can
you have the benefits of having an ideal
without having the crushing blow that
goes along with having the judge that
always regards you as insufficient so i
was trying to work that out in the
chapter and this is something i've had
to work out a lot as a clinical
psychologist it's like
well
let's say
you need a goal
but we don't want to let your distance
from the goal crush you so you got to
set up a goal and then you've got to
make the goal break the goal down into
parts so that you can move towards it
you have a fairly high likelihood of
doing it so that's a bit of practical i
wouldn't say advice it's it's because
it's better than advice it's it's some
practical knowledge about how to go
about achieving a name set a high aim
but differentiate it down so you know
what the next step is and then make the
next step difficult enough so you have
to push yourself past where you are but
but also provide yourself with a
reasonable probability of success it's
also what you do with children right you
want to push them because
they need to grow up and be more than
they are right but you don't want to
crush them with constant failure so what
you do is aim high and make the goal
proc difficult but proximal i think that
the best approach to
ameliorating inequalities to strengthen
the individual i mean that's and that's
what i've concentrated on doing like we
have this program
uh the self-authoring suite
and there's a component of that that
helps people write an autobiography and
another component that helps them write
an analysis of their personality and
another component that helps them write
out a plan for the future and we've used
that we've studied the effect of having
people write out a detailed plan for
their future and it's a proper plan it's
like okay look you you get to have what
you want three to five years down the
road you get to have the friends you
want you get to have the family you want
you get to have the career you want the
education you get you get to take care
of yourself properly you get to
withstand
the temptations of drug and alcohol
abuse and other sorts of impulsive
pleasures you get to make productive and
meaningful use of your time okay what
does that look like for you
write it out what does it look like just
you need a vision and then you need
another vision of how terrible things
could be if you let all your bad habits
get the upper hand and we've had people
do that in an experimental situation and
mostly they were college students and
the consequences of that there were two
consequences one was
general which was that
university students were about 30
percent more likely to stay in
university and got grades there were
about 25 percent better which is a
walloping effect but even more
interestingly and this is the coolest
thing i think that we ever discovered as
in our in our psychological research
we did this research in holland at the
um
at the erasmus university in rotterdam
at the rotterdam school of management
and we ran business students through the
future authoring program for multiple
years so several thousands of them and
we stratified them by gender and
ethnicity
pretty pretty rough cut men women and
then
dutch nationals and non-western ethnic
minorities okay and so the the
performance was like this the dutch
women were at the top
then the dutch men then the then the
non-western ethnic minority women then
the non-western ethnic minority men and
they were behind the dutch women by by
by they they should about an 80
decrement in performance really quite
catastrophic
two years after they did the future
authoring program they were ahead of the
dutch women
it just blew us away because it was and
it was a perfect indication of the fact
that you can use a psychological
intervention to ameliorate what looks
like a sociological problem let's say
you're a filmmaker and i'm a professor
okay we could so we differ there
right we're playing a different game
so you might say
and and as you go down into the
particulars of what we do it might even
become more different so if you look at
what a plumber does and a lawyer does as
as you get more and more fine-grained
they get more diverse but you might say
well the lawyer and the plumber are both
honest
they're both good citizens
and then you might nest that inside well
they're both acting out the archetype of
the hero
and
and like i said after that
you're out of the
things get too abstract for us to we
can't go farther than that i think that
you know i think the world is
order versus chaos let's say the balance
of order and chaos on a it's good and
evil on the background of order versus
chaos
and so you're either the hero or the
adversary or actually most of the time
you're a mixture of both
and it's best for you that's what our
culture has decided it's best for you
to take on the role of the hero to the
degree that that's possible and that
would be associated with love and that's
that
the
love
and i define that in the second book
particularly
what's the third book i wrote but in in
beyond order
are you working for the betterment of
being or are you working for harm
and everyone has a sense of this
and they know when they're working for
harm you're going to use what you think
to guide your action and the consequence
of that is going to be how your life
turns out
so i'm dead serious about what i write
because because i know what the pathway
is it's like you don't you don't
communicate in a false manner because if
you do you'll warp the structure that
guides your actions and you will
absolutely absolutely 100 suffer for
that i mean one of the things i've
learned as a clinical psychologist is
that i've never seen anyone it's really
a terrifying thing i've never seen
anyone get away with anything ever
it the chickens always come home to
roost so and sometimes it might you know
let's say you get away with something
it's like yeah you think so man
you wait five years from now seven years
from now it'll come back is that karma
it's more like yes i think it's the same
idea but it's more like
you you can't
you you don't have the power to
manipulate reality
like you have the power to bring about
reality in some sense because you
confront potential and through your
actions and and and your communicative
intent you turn potential into reality
but you don't have the you don't have
the power to bend reality without it
snapping you don't think so
you don't think so so you don't think
visionaries and influencers have the
ability to bend reality no i don't think
they bend it i think that they
they they i mean you can bring new
things into being but you can't you
can't get away with a falsehood
oh you can definitely bring new things
into being you can't get away with a
falsehood yes that's it okay makes sense
and and you can't get away with weak
thinking either
because
i mean any more than you can get away
with improper action it just doesn't
work
so you're you're contending it's what's
why i mean one of the themes in my
writing is the danger of falsehood
and at any at every level it's like well
if you tell the truth to the degree that
you can or at least don't lie that think
that's rule eight
then you have reality on your side you
got to decide man you want reality on
your side or do you want reality against
you
i wouldn't recommend the whole reality
against you thing because you're not
going to win you're going to get
flattened
and so i'm very careful with what i say
and i'm very careful with what i write
you need a value hierarchy
it's inevitable that you have a value
hierarchy
and that you look at the world through
it and that it should be well structured
and that there should be something of
divine importance at the top i would say
what should occupy the top position is
the realization for example that
each person is of divine value and that
the most appropriate way of interacting
with potential is by
embodying
and speaking the truth
that's not a bad way of
briefly conceptualizing what might be
at the highest
pinnacle of the value structure i would
say that's what the logos is
and so
the soul
is
a
the soul is what manifests itself in the
choice between different pathways
in in the choice between different ways
of transforming the potential of the
future into the actuality of the present
and it does that
by making ethical decisions by choosing
between good and evil at each choice
point and to the degree that it chooses
good then it takes the raw potential of
the future
and it transforms it into
the being of the present that is good
and to the degree that it does that in a
manner that's evil and contaminated by
malevolence and hatred and vengefulness
then it takes a pathway that corrupts
the world and makes things worse
and
it's the soul that's doing that and it's
the soul that's responsible for that and
it's also
that active part of the soul that's
shaping
the deeper soul in some sense which
would be something like the cumulative
consequence of all those choices
something akin to what people
more classically have referred to as
character something that i learned for
example from jean piaget he called that
an equilibrated state an equilibrated
state is like a game that everyone wants
to play and so if you set your household
up properly
then it's a game that everybody is
participating in voluntarily and that's
going to be predicated on the desire for
peace and the willingness to speak truth
and the ability to take responsibility
so that has to be part of your higher
order moral aim
and then when you're having a difficult
discussion with someone
the discussion is going to
be affected by that higher order moral
aim it's not going to be contaminated to
the same degree by your desire to
inflict pain and attain victory and you
know crush your opponent and punish them
for their previous sins and
indicate your disappointment things
they've done over the years and all of
that
one of the fundamental theses of 12
rules for life and also of maps of
meaning is that
because life is essentially tragic in
its fundamental essence you need a
sustaining meaning that's deep
and and profound and deep and profound
enough to get you through bad times
because there will be very bad times in
your life there'll be death and there'll
be illness and
there'll be disappointment of of all
sorts and and there'll be just the
standard difficulties of life in the
world to contend with and you really
must have something
that's profound and powerful to set up
against that and i think that
your
voluntary adoption of
the struggle to improve
being is the proper
uh antidote to that you want to present
yourself to the world in a manner that
that doesn't disgrace you in some sense
that that might be a good way to think
about it and you don't want to disgrace
yourself because the consequence of
disgrace is emotional dysregulation more
pain less positive emotion and so the
best way to present yourself is to stand
up
forthrightly and to stretch out you know
and to occupy some space and to to to
you make yourself sort of vulnerable by
doing that because you open up the front
of your body right but it's a sign of
confidence and that way people are most
likely to give you the benefit of the
doubt
and that's a good way to start
regulating your mood but not only does
it directly regulate your mood to stand
up because it's so tightly associated
like posture reflection is associated
with serotonin and emotional regulation
but also because
if you straighten up and you present
yourself in that manner then other
people are more likely to take you
seriously and that means they'll start
treating you as if you're a number one
lobster instead of a number 10 lobster
and that's another way that you can
at least give yourself the bloody
benefit of the doubt right and and and
and
and and confront the world in a
courageous manner of course you struggle
to remember it in your day-to-day life
because life is difficult and it's
harder to do things than not to do them
and it's harder to do them well than to
do them badly you know and it's easy to
sit around and be hopeless i don't mean
it's emotionally easy because it's not
but it's procedurally easy to be useless
and to fall back into your old habits
and to not discipline yourself and
it's it's a matter of continual practice
slow continual practice and i think a
good example of that is something like
weight lifting you know if you start a
weight lifting program which i would
recommend by the way because it it's
tremendously advantageous physically and
cognitively
you're not going to really see results
for a number of weeks and then the
results are rather slow but you can get
pretty decent results over a six-month
period and absolutely stellar results
over a couple of years and so you have
to make sure your time frame is right
and not to be too hard on yourself and
i did mention the future authoring
program
earlier and
one of the things i would recommend too
is if you're having a hard time
implementing your
your decisions say your ethical
decisions that you spend a bit more time
thinking them through and writing them
down and the future authoring program is
really helpful for that that's why we
designed it
and so
get your goals straight and continue to
practice every day and if you're not
succeeding then make your goals slightly
smaller you want to you want to make
your goals large enough so that they
challenge you but small enough so that
you have a reasonable probability of
succeeding at them on a day-to-day basis
and then you have to also understand
that if you fail on a given day like
let's say you're trying to quit smoking
and you quit for two weeks and then you
have a cigarette and you think oh my god
now i've screwed it up i've i'm not
quitting anymore you smoke a whole pack
of cigarettes it's like well
there's a couple of mistakes there and
one is
well just because you had a cigarette
doesn't mean you failed it just means
that you had a cigarette you can start
stopping again the next day
and the fact that you had one cigarette
in the last two weeks is a hell of a lot
better than the two weeks that you had
before that
and so you've got to be
realistically humble you've got to be
ambitious enough in your goals so that
you're pursuing something that you
regard as truly meaningful and
worthwhile
you know and maybe you can judge that to
some degree if you think about someone
you love attempting the same thing and
think about how you would feel if they
managed it and if you would feel good
then that's probably a good
um
what would you say that would be a good
evaluation strategy to use on yourself
so you want your goals to be of
sufficient nobility so that you can live
with yourself properly if you're
pursuing them but you want them to be
small enough so that you have a
reasonable probability of implementing
them you have to be very careful with
your hierarchies because
they tend towards inequality of
distribution that's one problem once
they're established they always also
tend to a form of tyranny because once a
hierarchy of competence has been
established it can be invaded by people
who use power as the means to attain
status in the hierarchy and that can
corrupt and and destroy even the entire
hierarchy so you have to be on guard for
that plus if your hierarchy becomes too
steep in its distribution so it's too
tiny a fraction of people at the top and
too great an agglomeration of people at
the bottom especially under conditions
of genuine privation then
the people at the bottom
it's not only unjust and unfair and
producing excess suffering but the
people at the bottom have nothing to
lose and might as well just flip the
hierarchy on its end
and that's not a good way to produce a
sustainable society you don't want to
put people in a position where they have
nothing to lose
especially if you have something to lose
but also just with regards to principles
of like fairness and justice let's say
most of your sanity
is socially distributed
and what i mean by that is well let's
say that you know how to behave you're
well socialized you can play with others
now i said already in this conversation
if you didn't learn to play with others
between the time you were two and four
you will never learn
and psychologists have beat their heads
against the wall trying to rehabilitate
anti-social children they can't do it
after the age of four
is that because areas of the brain just
don't develop
well it seems to be partly because the
kids fall farther and farther behind so
let's say you make the leap from
egocentric dependence on your mother at
two and three to immersion in a peer
group
well then then you you pick peers that
are at your same development level and
you chase each other up the
developmental ladder
and the longer you're out of that the
farther you fall behind
and so
you know kids five-year-old kids might
come across another five-year-old kid
who tends to cry too much
if they don't get their way
and they'll say we don't want to play
with the baby
and what they're saying is we have to
find someone who's at our developmental
level shares our developmental horizons
so that we can mutually scaffold our
further development now they're not
going to say that obviously but that's
the situation and kids
test each other out when they first meet
so do adults
game game game game can you play are you
playing at the same level as me i'm
playing my game at the level that will
further my development
can you play along with me if not well
maybe you're lower in status and i can
pull you up as a mentor maybe you're
higher in status and i can learn from
you but if you're a peer we can play
together anyways
if you're acceptable to your peers
and you behave well they'll accept you
and then they tell you all the time if
you're acting appropriately you know if
your jokes are funny if you're
dominating the conversation if you're
bringing something of value to the table
and all you have to do is pay attention
to the social cues
and you'll keep yourself regulated talk
to people about
taking care of themselves like they're
someone who they have responsibility for
and that's not a political issue too
it's it's uh it's an injunction to
assuming that you have a certain
intrinsic value
you know and that
it's necessary for that value to
manifest itself for you to
push yourself against the world to
challenge yourself because otherwise
what
you're capable of won't manifest itself
it has to be developed it has to be
called forth by necessity right you have
to pick a hard problem and try to solve
it and push yourself against it in order
for and you have to try to do that
truthfully and responsibly in order for
what it is that you're
intrinsically
capable of and composed of to come to
the forefront
and that seems like a very positive
thing as far as i'm concerned to
encourage people to be responsible for
themselves and for other people and also
to point out that
that you have a moral responsibility to
do so
for yourself just as you do for others
and
i i think that that message has been
very
helpful to people at least that's what
they've told me
the i and it's predicated that the rule
is predicated on the old judeo-christian
idea the oldest idea in some sense that
you know that there's a relationship
between
logos which is truthful speech and
communication and bringing things into
being from chaotic potential that's the
idea that's put forward in genesis and
also the idea that men and women alike
are made in the image of god which
suggests that like god
we have the capability of
affecting potential affecting the
possible future and turning it into the
actual present and that we do that at
least in part as a consequence of our
ethical choices first of all i i try to
be over prepared in some sense so i mean
i believe that if you're going to if
you're going to give a 20-minute lecture
you should have an hour of material at
hand because that way you have an
opportunity to sort of move
spontaneously through the material but
generally what i do now because i have a
lot of material
at hand a lot of stories and a lot of
things that i've a knowledge say that
i've accrued over the years usually
before a lecture also and this is the
hard part and i can do a lecture without
doing this but it's better if i do this
this is the hard part i'll sit down for
20 minutes with my eyes closed and i
figure out what the what the central
topic is so there's always a question
what's the question i'm trying to
address in this lecture and then i'll
figure out a pathway through it it's
like okay well here's the argument
here's point one here's point two here's
point three and there's possible
branches off those and then with each
point i usually have a collection of
stories and facts that i can use to
make the point that let's make the point
yeah yeah and then to buttress it and to
make it interesting and so it's a little
bit it's a little bit like
improvisational jazz i would say or even
improvisational piano because i play a
little bit of piano one so you lay out
the the story and then right you can use
the responses of the audience to guide
how you're going to walk through it
treat yourself
like you're someone that you care about
see i read this i read this
this
piece of work by jung a long while back
and it was a meditation on
um the injunction to treat
your neighbor as as you would like to be
treated something like that and what
jung pointed out which i really liked
was that that wasn't an injunction to be
nice to other people
it was an invitation to reciprocity it
was something like this it's like
you should figure out how you would like
to be treated
like you were taking care of yourself
not how you would like people to respond
to you it's more important than that
it's like imagine you had a child that
you really cared for
and and someone said well
people will treat this child exactly
like you want them to but you have to
figure out what that is and so then
you'd have to sit down for like a month
and you think okay well how do you want
your child to be treated you don't want
everyone just to be nice to him you know
you want people to challenge him and you
want people to discipline him and you
want people to tell him when he's wrong
it's like you don't just want everyone
to be nice that's that's pathetic it's
pathetic isn't there's no challenge in
that and so
well you want to treat other people like
you would like to be treated well then
you have to figure out how would you
like to be treated
and well you'd like people to fawn all
over you and just lay everything at your
feet it's like no
that's that's not something you'd wish
for for someone that you were taking
care of
and then then there's an additional
problem which is it's often the case
that people will treat other people
better than they treat themselves that
happens extremely
frequently so one of the things i
pointed out chapter 2 was that
if you have a dog and you take him to a
vet and the vet gives you your
prescription medicine you'll go buy the
medicine and you will give it to the dog
and you will do it properly but if you
go yourself to a doctor and you get a
prescription there's one that there's a
30 chance you won't even pick up the
medication and if you do there's a 50
chance that you won't administer it to
yourself properly
and so i really thought about that when
i first came across that statistic it
really it was another one of those
little facts i thought what the hell's
up with that it's like you'll do it for
your dog so obviously you'll do it for
something you care about and you're
conscientious enough so you'll actually
do it so like why wouldn't you do it for
you your dog likes you you know even
your dog would rather that you did but
but you don't you don't and and it's
actually one of the reasons that modern
medicine doesn't work nearly as well as
it could because people just don't take
their medication you make the world a
much better place a much worse place if
you don't take care of yourself
so you should bloody well take care of
yourself you know because
well that's what the chapters about it's
partly because you have something
valuable to bring into the world
that's the thing about being an
individual it's the thing that western
civilization has always recognized that
as an individual you have a light that
you have to bring into the world and
that if you don't bring it into the
world the world is a dimmer place and
that's a bad thing because when the
world is a dim place it can get very
very very dark
and so it's not just so that you feel
better and not just so that you're a
number one lobster not none of those
things you need to take care of yourself
because you're in the best position to
do that and it's necessary for you to
take care of yourself despite the fact
that we're mortal and vulnerable and
self-conscious and capable not only
capable of doing terrible things but
actually do them despite all that
you you're still you still have that
responsibility you know yourself by
watching and paying attention
that's why the egyptians worshiped horus
the eye
as a god they knew that attention was
important and and the mesopotamians did
the same thing with their god marduk
it's not thinking
exactly it's not imagination it's just
it's watching like you're like you're a
snake
a snake you know is a
symbol of wisdom in part because
a stink is a symbol of many things but
wisdom is one of them
i suppose it's because encounters with
snakes that
if they're not fatal they make you wise
because a snake watches like
cold-bloodedly
with no
emotional reaction
just to see what's there
doesn't allow
symbolically speaking doesn't allow
what
is wanted or desired to interfere with
what is observed so you watch yourself
like that as if you don't know who you
are i have a theory that i've been
working on for a very long time and what
happens when i read something is i plug
it into the theory so i know the full
outline of the theory it's it'd probably
take me 45
50 hours to lay it out in lectures i've
done that online and then but i keep it
grows and grows and grows and grows and
i know where to put everything i so if i
read something i think oh yes that slots
there
and so and so you store it as well if
somebody asks you a question you need to
use that fact you have it somewhere
still where you bring it and say okay
but it has to be related to this work
that i've been doing over time yeah yeah
so it's kind of like there there's this
technique called memory castle that
people have used for centuries to
remember things and so what you do is
you you you sit and you you imagine a
might be a place that you know like a
lit a geographic place a house
and then you can place the things that
you remember imagine you walk through
the house you can place the things that
you want to remember at different
locations in the house but you have to
you have to turn what you're remembering
into an image and then you can walk
through the house and and you can lift
things up and find what it is that
you're trying to remember i sort of do
that with this theory it's like it's
it's been interesting i've literally
worked on it for it's been 40 years and
so i know the
i know the story and i know it's
branches and i keep adding to it and
adding to it and shifting pieces around
from time to time i think
a tremendous amount of what you might
regard as
shadow integration which
in
the parlance of behavioral psychologists
would be something like assertiveness
training right it's training in how to
stand up for yourself and and for your
let's say for your better self which
would be the self that you could use
productively over a medium to long
period of time that would be of use to
you but also views to people around you
so it's a self that's bounded by the
necessity of taking care of yourself but
also simultaneously taking care of the
people around you
i think that the simplest way to start
that work
is to consult your resentment you know
it's easy to become bitter about life
and to become angry because of course
life is difficult and it's full of
disappointments and people are also
subject to betrayal on the part of
themselves and on the part of people
that hypothetically care for them and so
it's easy to get bitter and to be
resentful
and
resentment is a very useful emotion even
though i think it's one of the most
uh
damaging emotions if it's not dealt with
properly so if you're resentful
basically means
only one of two things it either means
you should grow up and quit whining and
get on with your life or it means that
you're being subject to
tyrannical forces of one form or another
may be emanating from you maybe a
consequence of the natural environment
maybe a consequence of society you're
being subject to tyrannical forces and
you're not
putting your own
best interests forward like in that
broader sense that i described and i
don't mean your selfish narrow
interests that only serve the purposes
of instantaneous gratification i mean
your own best interests in terms of
developing your character over the span
of your life
if you're resentful
it either means that you're immature and
that you should grow the hell up and so
you need to figure out how much of your
resentment is is is that and and maybe
allied with the desire to find other
things or people to blame
but the other possible option is that
you have something to say or do
right because you're in a situation
where
you're violating your own internal
ethical standards
and you're being required pressured
let's say to say things you don't
believe or to do things that you believe
to be wrong
and you need to determine you need to
start to strategize and plan how you can
rectify that so that you can say what
you mean like if you're negotiating with
a marital partner for example and there
are
um issues in your marriage that aren't
making you happy well the first thing is
you have to take note of that right to
see that you're actually unhappy
the second is that you have to be
willing to engage in a certain amount of
conflict because in order to sort out
what's disturbing you you're going to
have to lay your concerns out on the
table
and say well look this is bothering me
you don't have to say well i'm right and
you're wrong and you have to fix this
you have to say well i've noticed that
this
pattern of interaction or lack of
interaction say in our relationship is
making me resentful and angry and the
danger of that of course is you're going
to take it out on yourself and your
partner
the danger is passion passive
aggressiveness you know you're not going
to respond to your partner positively
when they do something good if you're
resentful about them
and you're not going to respond to
yourself properly and so you have to lay
it out on the table but sort of in a
spirit of ignorant humility it's like
look i'm frustrated i'm feeling this way
about our relationship here's what i
think might be going wrong maybe on my
part and maybe on your part and here's
what i envision as a possible solution
that's also really necessary if you're
going to say what you have to say which
is to manifest yourself properly in the
world is you can't just complain about
what's wrong you have to think well what
would my minimal preconditions for
satisfaction be you have to offer that
to the person that you're negotiating
with
and so
then you learn to abide by the truth to
the degree that you can do that and no
one does it perfectly you know but
it it's very useful because
you're not storing up
a whole
sequence of memories about how you were
unfairly treated and abused and betrayed
instead you're trying to stay on top of
it and to note your unhappiness and
dissatisfaction when it manifests itself
and to accept that that's the case and
then to analyze that to see if it's your
problem like i said with regards to
maturity or if it indicates that there's
an injustice
in the manner in which
you and the world are interacting and
then to work to set that right even in
small ways and
so it's it's a matter of character
logical development and that makes you
that makes you stronger over time and
partly what you need you know in order
to do that is you have to really
understand and we do this this is why we
built in the future authoring program we
built this section where you have to
outline your most dismal future right
what your future would be like if you
let all your bad habits and
characterological weaknesses have the
upper hand and the reason we did this is
because
you can't be
uh
you can't straighten yourself out merely
as a consequence of hope let's say you
lay out a vision for the future and you
think about what your life would be
what you'd like your life to be like and
then that makes you hopeful and it
motivates you because it gives you
something worthwhile and higher order to
work for
right and that's useful that's positive
emotion working for you because positive
emotion is experienced in relationship
to goals but it's not not as useful as
also being chased by something you're
terrified by and if you have a good
sense of how you'd fall apart if you
stayed weak and just exactly what kind
of hell that would be
then when you determine to do something
like to tell the truth and to say what
you think and to not do things that you
hate
then
you're going to be pulled along by the
purpose that your vision has provided
for you but also pushed along by your
desire to avoid the worst forms of hell
that you've already outlined for
yourself personally and that can also
help you be brave enough to stand up
in a situation that we would require
conflict because if you have something
to say
and you have something to negotiate
about with someone then there's going to
be a certain amount of conflictual
dialogue
that accompanies that right it to to lay
out a set of problems and to describe
the fact forthrightly that those
problems characterize a relationship and
then to seek for solutions is quite
stressful in the short term
and it's really easy to avoid and so
people avoid it all the time and then
they store up grievances across the span
of their relationships and eventually
the grievances mount to the point where
they return in monstrous form and just
eat everything up that's where you get
divorces or that's where you explode at
your boss and end up fired or that's
where you you know you develop high
blood pressure over 15 years because you
can't stand all the accumulated uh uh
mons
all the accumulated monsters in your
closet and and you drink yourself into
oblivion because you can't stand your
life that's all
you know very counterproductive but it's
easy to avoid that necessary conflict on
a moment-to-moment basis because it's
very stressful to
speak forthrightly about genuine
conflicts especially when you're dealing
with important parts of your life
but otherwise you don't straighten them
out and then you have to carry all that
forward so you need to be terrified of
the consequences of not speaking your
peace
and that can counterbalance the terror
of actually trying to have a
conversation all of the people that i
know who have become successful in any
way
use
a structured means to
organize their time they have lists of
things to do like they have every day
there's a list of things to do that day
every week there's a list of things to
do that week every month there's a list
of things to do
that month you know at every level of
temporal resolution there's a sequence
of plans and those plans are implemented
on a day-to-day basis you you cannot be
and successful isn't the right way of
thinking about it because i'm not
thinking about you know i'm not really
thinking about rising up the corporate
ladder you know you know what i mean and
that's sort of what success has come to
mean in our culture that isn't what i
mean
you can't have a life that you're going
to find acceptable
without that because you need the
vision and the plans to give you purpose
and direction that's where all your
positive emotion comes from all your
motivation is laying out plans that are
worth attaining and then observing
yourself moving towards them that's the
source of most positive meaning and then
also without that structure
you're so lost that you're going to be
anxious and overwhelmed it's really like
being in a foreign country
like isolated and alone with no map i
don't know where the hell i am i don't
know what the hell i'm doing you know
the rains are going to come the storms
are going to come and maybe it's winter
and i don't know where i am or where you
know that life is suffering and that we
make it worse with our malevolence i
think everyone understands that to be
true
but the second is that the best way to
confront that is to shoulder
responsibility
voluntarily and to live in truth i think
those are even more powerful ideas
because you could say that the cure for
a malaise or the treatment for a disease
is more powerful than the malaise or the
disease itself and if responsibility and
truth are antidotes to suffering and
malevolence then that means that they're
they're
of they have a power that's transcendent
over suffering malevolence you should
use a calendar to structure your days
because if you know what you're doing
tomorrow it decreases your anxiety
substantially because you need that kind
of structure
you need a pathway you need to know
you need to have a map and you need to
know where you're located on the map and
you need to know how you're moving
forward and that gives you hope because
you're moving towards goals that you
regard as
worthwhile and it stops you from being
anxious because you're not entirely
directionless and lost
and so learning how to manage your time
is useful and you can start with a
calendar you can start with simple
things like you can put in well
when you're likely to go to bed and when
you're likely to get up and and
regulating that's useful that should be
relatively ritualistically consistent
make friends with people who want the
best for you
and that's a meditation on my own
childhood in adolescence to some degree
i had friends who wanted the best for me
and friends who didn't and you know they
were friends who
some of them were aiming up and some of
them were aiming down and if you have a
friend that's aiming down and you do
something that's aiming up then they're
generally not that happy about it you
know they try to top your accomplishment
with one of their own hypothetical or
real or put down what you're doing or
offer you a cigarette if you're trying
to quit and you've kind of done that
successfully or a drink if you've been
drinking too much and are trying to stop
being an alcoholic you know or or
yeah they're cynical and bitter and and
devoted towards no good and sometimes
that's family members too and sometimes
it's even part of you you know but
this chapter is a injunction to people
is like
like you have an ethical responsibility
to take care of yourself you have an
ethical responsibility to surround
yourself with people who have the
courage and and faith and
wisdom to wish you well when you've done
something good
and to stop you when you're doing
something destructive and if your
friends aren't like that then they're
not your friends
and maintaining your friendships with
them might not even be in their interest
and so it's a tricky argument to make
because i'm not saying you know whenever
anyone's in trouble you should you know
push them into a ditch and then give
them a couple of kicks that's that's not
the idea
the idea is that but i had a couple of
rules i didn't write about one was be
careful
uh be careful about whom you share good
news with and another was be careful
about whom you share bad news with and
everyone those rules ring in people's
minds quite quickly a friend is someone
you can share good news with you know
you go to them and you say hey look this
good thing happened to me and they say
look i'm so happy that that happened to
you like way to be and they don't think
god dammit why didn't that happen to me
and like you know you didn't deserve it
here's a bunch of reasons you're stupid
and why it won't work it's like that's
not helpful and so i would say like if
people are
you know what the other thing people are
doing if they're trying to drag you down
let's say is they're trying to see if
you'll put up with it because they have
this idea that maybe life isn't worth
living and things aren't good and then
if they can
besmirch let's say to use an archaic
term something that's pristine and good
then they demonstrate to themselves that
there is no true ideal and that there's
no necessary reason to be responsible
and to strive forward and so they use
you as a test case you know i'll just
push you down into the low lobster bin
and see how you respond and if you put
up with it then yeah my cynicism is
fully justified make one room in your
house as beautiful as possible
that's that's what i'm writing about now
um
i i talked a lot about already about the
necessity of cleaning your room which is
you know in some sense a foolish piece
of advice because it seems so obvious
but it's not obvious at all and you'll
find if you try it especially if you're
in a household that's not very
functional that you'll
encounter obstacles that you couldn't
imagine existed while you're trying to
put your life in order and
you can take
your surroundings beyond order and and
and move towards beauty and that's
unbelievably useful because
while beauty calls people to their
higher being i would say and to make
friends with beauty is to
introduce yourself and introduce
yourself very carefully to one of the
mysteries of life that make it worth
living the aims that you have in your
life the ethical aims and those are the
aims that direct your actions also
direct your perceptions that this is
true at a neurophysiological level and
that much of the way that the world
manifests itself to you
is a consequence of the structure of
your ethics so it's your ethical
structure that's instantiated
neurophysiologically that
serves as an intermediary between the
world of phenomena let's say
objective phenomena and your perception
of that
and you see the world through an ethical
lens add
small goals now if that doesn't work
like if you can't make the goals small
enough to achieve you know it might be
that you're not being humble enough with
regards to your conceptions of your own
ability but you can tell if the goal
that you put forward is a reasonable one
if you're actually implementing it
because if you're not then by definition
it's not a reasonable goal you know like
let's say you're you're sleeping all the
time in your room is just a bloody
complete disaster you know and you think
well i should clean up my room it's like
well maybe you can't but maybe tomorrow
you could hang up two shirts you know or
you could you could move two shirts from
your bedroom to the laundry room or you
could bag up a bag of dirty clothes that
you could conceivably take to a
laundromat and you just do that one
thing you know
if you do if your room is a catastrophe
and you do that one thing and then you
did one thing like that for 15 days or
20 days maybe your place would be in
order
and so the trick is to get the
trajectory i want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe nation you made it here
all the way to the end and i love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
below on this video i will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome if you want 60 minutes to start
your year with success check the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there you're more likely to do
something
if you have already prepared
and stepped it through
you're already more likely to do
something if you already prepared